"Star Wars" fans got plenty of the things
they expected from the first teaser trailer
for the upcoming "Obi-Wan Kenobi" series,
set to debut on Disney+ in May.
Fans have known since August 2019 that Ewan
McGregor would be reprising his role as the
Jedi Master, along with Hayden Christensen's
return as Darth Vader, since the project was
announced a few years ago.
"Hello there!"
However, there were a few surprises in the
"Obi-Wan Kenobi" trailer some fans never expected.
Chief among them were the appearance of the
Inquisitors.
The Inquisitors are an order of Force-sensitive
hunters that were trained by Darth Vader in
order to capture, kill, or corrupt any surviving
Jedi in the galaxy.
Many of them appear in "Star Wars" series,
like "Star Wars: Rebels," as well as various
related comics and video games, like "Star
Wars: Jedi Fallen Order."
Despite their popularity as villains, this
is the first time that they have appeared
in a live-action context, similar to Cad Bane's
appearance on "The Book of Boba Fett."
However, not every "Star Wars" fan who watched
"Rebels" is jumping for joy at the Inquisitors'
live-action debut.
In fact, it's the appearance of the Grand
Inquisitor that has some fans scratching their
heads.
Fans on Reddit made it clear that this live-action
Grand Inquisitor was close to the version
of the character we see in "Star Wars: Rebels,"
but didn't quite look right.
One user wrote,
"I realize the 'Rebels' style is a cartoonified,
stretched-out look.
But even so, I would have preferred him look
a little thinner in the face."
Another user observed,
"He definitely looks less slim than I thought
he'd look in live-action."
Another responded that,
"In 'Rebels,' he gives off the air of a diffident,
aristocratic fencer.
I'm not getting that vibe from him.
He looks like a haunted house reject."
It is worth noting that the Grand Inquisitor's
species, the Pau'ans are notoriously slim,
and this character is no exception.
In "Rebels," he is depicted as noticeably
taller and thinner than the majority of characters.
Previous live-action depictions of the Pau'an
species are also extremely slim.
One Reddit poster wrote,
"First thing I noticed as well.
Aren't their heads a little longer too?
He didn't look much like the Pau'ans from
'Revenge of The Sith' in my opinion."
This, of course, doesn't mean that this new
portrayal should be automatically discounted.
Cad Bane's appearance in "The Book of Boba
Fett" also led to some minor fan outcry, but
was overall well-liked by at least a portion
of the viewing audience.
"Consider this my final lesson.
Look out for yourself."
Now that we've seen what the "Obi-Wan Kenobi"
version of the Grand Inquisitor will look
like, it's important to go over who exactly
the Inquisitors are in the world of "Star
Wars."
As we mentioned, they are an order of Jedi
hunters trained by Darth Vader to assist him
in the Jedi Purge following the events of
Order 66.
While their exact numbers aren't well-known,
quite a few make appearances in "Rebels" and
other media.
Putting aside the Grand Inquisitor, one of
the other Inquisitors we see rendered in live-action
for the very first time is the Fifth Brother,
played by Sung Kang.
He is the helmet-sporting gentleman leading
a squad of Stormtroopers at the 1-minute,
15-second mark in the teaser trailer.
He's also one of the several Inquisitors to
make multiple appearances in "Rebels."
Another is Reva, a brand new Inquisitor whose
story is, thus far, unknown.
Considering that she hasn't yet made an appearance
in any other Star Wars media, her fate is
the most ambiguous of the characters we've
seen in the trailer.
Then, of course, there's the Grand Inquisitor,
the leader of the bunch who terrorized Kanan
Jarrus and Ezra Bridger on multiple occasions
in "Rebels."
A former Jedi, the Grand Inquisitor is about
as dangerous as the Empire gets without Vader
getting involved.
In other words, his involvement in the events
of "Obi-Wan Kenobi" spells big trouble for
both Obi-Wan and the young Luke Skywalker.
Thankfully, that intimidating presence is
present in the show's trailer.
We'll just have to wait and see whether or
not the fans will be able to overcome his
new look.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Star Wars characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.